こんちゃす！はじめしゃちょーです！
あのー突然です申し訳ないんですけど
100万円企画第6弾いきなりなんですけどやろうと思います
第1弾亀の池
第2弾遊戯王カード100万円
第3弾遊園地貸し切り
第4弾うまい棒
第5弾うまい棒配ったやつ
そして第6弾になったわけなんですけども
あのー...本当にこれやる予定がなくて
本当に今日突然やりました
たまたま今日家の近くのショッピングモール行って、
なんか自転車買おうと思ってこう
ようへいくんのチャリ見てたんですけど、
そしたら、外見ると
「えっ何あれ何あれ！」
って言うくらい不思議な自転車が置いてありまして、
てか自転車かどうかも怪しかったんですよ
で乗ってる人にちょっと聞いてみたら
やっぱ自転車って言うことで
あの実際にちょっと乗らせていただきました
自転車に乗ってる人「日本にはこの1台しかなくて」
ん～ん
うぉぉぉ！
すごい深い！
やべぇ。やばいよ
よ:メカ感がやっぱ
新、新時代や。
めっちゃスピード出るこれ多分
惚れました！
えっちょっとまってまて！
そもそも自転車ってああいうのじゃないじゃん？
あれ自転車なの！？
えっ！ほしい...
そう思った瞬間僕もうネットですぐあの自転車のなんか色々調べて
値段を見たら
でした
それでもうあの本当に欲しくなりまして
でそのその人も自転車を売ってるらしくてこらもう俺買うしかねぇなって
言うわけで実は今日初めて会ったんですけど今
家に！来ております
でなんか話を聞くと
買ってから2ヶ月
作るのに2ヶ月かかるって聞いたんですけども
なんか...すごい良い人で
すごい僕が乗りたそうにしすぎてて
あのーその方がなんと
旅中なんですけど
今！今！乗ってるその！
自転車を！
くれまぁぁす！ありがとうございまぁぁす！
早速招き入れましょう
というわけで今日、たまたまショッピングモールに行ったら
出会いました
小川さん「小川まさひろと申します」
あっよろしくお願いします！
すげぇ形の自転車に乗ってたんですよ
...
ね
小川さん「そうですｗ」
すいませんｗｗ
小川さん「人見知りで申し訳ないっすｗ」
でなんか色々お話をお聞きすると
まあ、近未来の自転車を
小川さん「ええ。」
開発されてるということで
小川さん「はい」
小川さん「すごい乗り物でまあ」
小川さん「健康にもいいし環境にもいいし」
う～ん
小川さん「で、まあ快適ですごい軽くて」
小川さん「スピードも出るし」
小川さん「車のいろんな課題を解決できる乗り物だと思ってるんですね」
小川さん「これからもうちょっと日本の法律に合わせて」
小川さん「ちっちゃい車体のものを作って電動にして」
小川さん「何とか涼しいようにすればもうみんなに乗ってもらえる」
小川さん「素晴らしい乗り物になるんじゃないかなぁと思ってるので」
小川さん「これをぜひ日本に広めたいなぁと思って」
小川さん「やってます。」
任せてください！
いやもうなんかホントぱっと見で
一目惚れしちゃって
100万円なら出せると思って
来た！来た！と思ったんですけど、
作るのに2ヶ月ぐらいかかるって聞いて
まあ2ヶ月かぁ...
と思っていたところ！
今乗ってた本体を
貰えることになりました！ありがとうございます！！
小川さん「ありがとうございます。」
本当にすいません...
えっ
小川さん「そうですねええ」
小川さん「ベロモービルを日本中に広めるという」
小川さん「日本全国テストライブツアーというのをやってて、」
小川さん「今日16日目だったんですけど」
小川さん「いえいえもう帰りだったんで全然」
あ！本当ですか
金額のほうはちなみに...
小川さん「えー今全国ツアー中で」
小川さん「10％OFF」
おお！
小川さん「108万くらい」
108万。
小川さん「もういっちょ今乗ってた」
あ！中古車ってことで
小川さん「中古車ってことなので」
小川さん「まああと10万円」
あっ！
あと大体...
値段で言うと
小川さん「98万かなｗ」
98万円！
98万円でいいんですか？
小川さん「はい」
よろしくお願いします！
よかったぁ
現金100万円持っててよかったぁ
100万円企画！100万円の！
近未来自転車買ってみたでぇぇす！
失礼しますお会計します
生々しくて申し訳ないｗ
安くしてもらって
98万円でございます
買わせていただきます！
小川さん「ありがとうございました」
いや本当なんか...運命的な出会いをした
のかなと思って
大切に乗らせていただきます
小川さん「是非乗ってください」
ありがとうございます...
突然の100万円企画
近未来の自転車買ってみましたー！
ｗｗｗｗｗ
中がすごいです中が
これがあれです
ハンドルチャリのハンドルで、
こうやってブレーキになってて
で奥にあるのがペダルです
待ってｗｗ
ライトも！ライトも付きます
あの　曲がる時用のランプも付きます
ハイというわけでいかがでしょうか
100万円の自転車でございます
もう見た瞬間見た目で一目惚れしちゃって
いや本当にいい人でよかったっす
いやこれでさだってこれ乗って街歩いてみ？
というわけで今のところ
これに乗ってるのはどうやら世界で
僕だけみたいでございます
初の購入者らしいんで
早速近未来の100万円自転車
乗ってみましょう
よし。じゃあ行ってきます
ｗｗｗ
見てｗｗ
でもめっちゃ早いんでよこれ！やばくない！？
キッキッキッキ(ブレーキ)
うん
よ:結構早いんだね
いや、あのーどうやら80km/hくらいまで行くらしい
よ:マジで！？ｗ
交通法的によると軽車両なんで
よ:ふんふん
一通のところでも曲がっていいらしいです
チャリと同じだね
よ:う～ん
ヘルメットもいらないし
よ:確かに
っていう感じよ
ほらもう
よ:早いｗｗ早いｗ
～ED～